qui réussit enfin à se mettre d'accord
sur le projet de satellite de télévision
directe tdf 1
en principe il doit être lancé en
juillet 86 un protocole d'accord déjà
été signé en octobre dernier il prévoit
le partage des quatre canaux du
satellite de pour nous et deux pour
luxembourg mais voilà qu'au moment où
les discussions techniques viennent de
reprendre des nuages s'amoncellent
encore sur le projet et des
luxembourgeois parle de nouveau de se
rallier plutôt un projet de satellite
américain
hubert coudurier la france at-elle viser
trop haut elle décide en 1979 de lancer
avec l'allemagne de satellites jumeaux
tv sat étaient des f1 suivi de tdf 2
c'est la volonté de créer un espace
audiovisuel européen
mais les investissements sont
considérables et des difficultés
techniques retardent le lancement du
satellite
aujourd'hui on se demande si une
technologie aussi lourd ne pourrais pas
être remplacé par de simples satellite
de télécommunications quant aux
standards hexagonal adoptée par thomson
et philips ne risque-t-il pas de nous
isoler au sein du marché international
reste le coût des antennes de réception
pour payer 7000 francs il faut des
programmes vraiment attractif ce de rtl
télévision par exemple
c'est là qu'apparaît le méchant
satellite coca cola coronet comme ces
canaux coûte trois fois moins cher il
permet la clt de faire monter les
enchères
c'est à dire payer - et obtenir à tiers
du marché publicitaire des télévisions
hertziennes en france une prétention
jugés exorbitants
ce qui est important pour nous c'est que
c'est un projet qui a une véritable
considération internationale qui a fait
l'objet d'un certain nombre d'années que
c'est sûr déjà par l'emballement
français qui à sa technologie qui à son
financement qui est appuyée sur deux
possibilités de programme réel je n'ai
pas besoin de faire une annonce pour
pouvoir en parler mais votre but c'est
quand même de chercher d'autres
partenaires que la saleté
mon but c'est que le projet marche gagne
réussissent parce qu'il est important
c'est un enjeu important par conséquent
mon but
à cet égard c'est de réunir les
meilleures conditions pour parvenir à
cet objectif c'est-à-dire les meilleurs
partenaires possibles il est vrai que le
luxembourg est un partenaire privilégié
sur lequel nous avons conduit un client
nous avons conduit
les négociations ça n'est pas le seul
événement pour les français le projet
cornette n'est pas crédible pas plus que
la si elle tenait un passage obligé
reste à trouver un autre montage
financier et d'autres candidats
européens voient américain on est le
temps presse